da zusammen zdf heute live ihr euer live
stream zu aktuellen ereignissen und
diskussionen und wir hatten eigentlich
damit gerechnet dass die pressekonferenz
der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz und der
bundesregierung in einer halben stunde
erstattet aber wie ihr seht das ganze
läuft schon deswegen schalten wir sofort
darüber nach berlin ansatz der auch den
schnellstmöglichen zugang zu diesen
leistungen ermöglicht zweitens die das
thema register modernisierung hier geht
es letztlich um war datensparsamkeit
also woran es liegt dass bürgerinnen und
bürger ihre daten nur einmal zur
verfügung stellen müssen und dann immer
wieder freigeben können für die
verwendung in unterschiedlichen
kontexten und das erfordert aber dass
alle register im lande auch wirklich
digitalisiert sind dafür sind die
rechtlichen grundlagen geschaffen jetzt
geht es um die umsetzung und das dritte
sehr sehr wichtige thema ist die
elektronische identität beweist sich ein
mensch aus auch bei einer hohen
sicherheitsrelevanz und da ist der
ausgangspunkt für uns der
personalausweis mit seinem digitalen
chip das alles soll in zukunft auf dem
handy verfügbar sein und dann müssen
eben anwendungsbeispiele gefunden werden
und da unsere anstrengungen hier haben
wir berichtet dass geht um sehr ganz
praktische dinge wie hotel als hotel
einchecken oder beantragen eines kontos
und wir sind hier im grunde in einem
wettlauf mit den amerikanischen
plattformen weil die natürlich auch
intensitäten anbieten aber wenn wir eine
digitale souveränität haben wollen denn
wer eine eigenes sicherheitsniveau haben
wollen dann ist es vernünftig dafür auch
staatlicherseits ein angebot zu machen
wir haben dann uns mit corona noch
einmal beschäftigt die entwicklung ist
extrem erfreulich zurzeit was die
fallzahlen anbelangt und
wir können sagen dass sich die
anstrengungen der vergangenen monate
gelohnt haben dass sich die erfolge
jetzt auch zum teil schon einstellen
dass das wetter natürlich auch seinen
beitrag dazu leistet aber wir dürfen
nicht vergessen corona ist damit nicht
verschwunden und das was uns sorge macht
ist die sogenannte delta variante die
sich jetzt in großbritannien wieder sehr
stark ausbreitet und dort im augenblick
gerade zu einem exponentiellen wachstum
führt und deshalb fühlen wir uns
bestätigt seitens des bundes dass wir
sehr starke einschränkung
einreisebeschränkungen gemacht haben für
großbritannien und für indien auch ist
ja die früher indische variante genannte
variante
sie ist augenscheinlich in ihrer
ausbreitung aggressiver das heißt wenn
man sozusagen die freie bewegung
ermöglicht dann wird sie sich gegenüber
der sogenannten britischen variante auch
wieder durchsetzen und wir sind im
grunde in einem wettlauf mit dem impfen
jeder tag den wir eine geringe
nachweisbarkeit dieser variante haben
ist ein guter tag wir sind jetzt bei 25
prozent
der anstieg ist recht langsam im
augenblick und ich hoffe dass das so
bleibt
es gibt jetzt einige fragen zu klären
die gerade auch die bundesländer
beschäftigen nämlich wie sieht es aus
mit großveranstaltungen sieht das aus
mit sportveranstaltungen
hierfür haben wir den cd essen den
auftrag gegeben sich miteinander zu
verständigen
anlehnend auch an vorgehensweisen die
wir schon aus dem vergangenen jahr
kennen und wir haben verabredet dass wir
uns alle vier wochen bund und länder
zusammen schalten auf der cd s ebene und
dass es in der zweiten augusthälfte noch
einmal im mp geben wird wo wir uns dann
anschauen wie es der im fortschritt wie
ist es mit den mutationen wie ist es mit
der pandemischen lage oder epidemischen
lagen von nationaler tragweite und ein
punkt der für die länder von großer
bedeutung
wie geht es weiter mit dem impfen einmal
welche dosen werden geliefert wir haben
für den monat juli noch kein ganz klares
bild und wir es ist die frage wie lange
sollen die impfzentren weiterbetrieben
werden wir werden ja im herbst wieder
beginnen müssen mit nach impfungen der
älteren generation also wie booster
impfung für man so schön sagt
und es gibt viele gründe warum die
länder sagen dass in einem gewissen
umfang im centern auch weiter betrieben
werden sollten
und darüber wird man dann sprechen
müssen und das sollen die
gesundheitsminister vorbereiten die
haben nächste woche eine
gesundheitsministerkonferenz
und dann werden wir darüber auch weiter
auf der cd s ebene oder wenn es
notwendig ist auf der mp ebene
miteinander in kontakt sein
also wir haben ein sommer der uns viele
möglichkeiten gibt die wir lange monate
nicht hatten aber wir sollten nicht
sorglos sein sondern die werke immer
wieder sehr sehr genau beobachten und
ich denke auch im sommer sonst das
testen für die die noch nicht geimpft
sind weiter eine große rolle spielen
herzlichen dank das war es von meiner
seite
meine damen und herren tatsächlich viele
punkte die heute im rahmen unserer
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz aufgerufen
worden ich möchte auch beginnen mit dem
thema energie es ist völlig unstrittig
und uns allen bewusst und wie ländern
hier müssen wir schneller werden wir
haben uns ambitionierte klimaziele
gesetzt
es gibt dazu auch entsprechende
gerichtsentscheidungen die deutlich
machen hier ist dringender
handlungsbedarf
wir sehen einen großen umbau unserer
ganzen wirtschaftsstruktur und der
industrie die sich völlig neu ausrichten
das heißt wir werden einen erhöhten
strombedarf in den nächsten jahren auch
haben und dafür müssen die
entsprechenden voraussetzungen
geschaffen werden und die entsprechende
infrastruktur dh der trassen ausbau muss
vorangehen und er muss schneller
vorangehen
wir haben bis 20 26 7700 kilometer
geplant anpassen ausbau 1600 sind jetzt
erst fertiggestellt und 730 kilometer
genehmigt schon allein die zahlen machen
deutlich wenn man auch weiß wie die
planungs vorläufe sind wie
bürgerbeteiligung laufen welche
dinge anders zu berücksichtigen sind
dann in der umsetzung dass wir wirklich
alle anstrengungen unternehmen müssen um
hier schneller zu werden dazu wird es
auch natürlich weiter jenseits der
wahlkampf situationen und
koalitionsverhandlungen wird es weiter
auf bund länder ebene einen direkten
austausch geben müssen um alle varianten
und alle verfahren die uns eine
beschleunigung ermöglichen auch wirklich
auszuschöpfen
ich will hinzufügen dass auch ein
anderer tagesordnungspunkt sich
mittelbar mit diesem thema
auseinandergesetzt haben nämlich das
ganze thema der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit wir haben
hier bund länder über den tellerrand
hinausgeblickt haben natürlich gesagt
und bekräftigt dass wir uns auch bei dem
globalen entwicklungen und diskussionen
die es gibt nicht nur anschließen
sondern sie auch vorantreiben wollen die
stg spielen eine große rolle
ich habe das selbst erlebt als präsident
von metropolis von diesem städtenetzwerk
bei den konferenzen es wird nach
deutschland geguckt wie gehen wir damit
um nicht nur beim thema klima sondern es
gibt viele andere dinge fairer handel
der rechtsstaatlichkeit stärkung von
kunst und kultur
das ganze thema bezahlbare wohnen
bezahlbares wurden das sind themen die
weltweit eine rolle spielen und die stg
es formulieren die grundlage für ein
gutes zusammenleben und eine gute
international vernetzte entwicklung
wir wollen und werden der partner sein
zur erreichung dieser ziele auch das hat
uns also heute beschäftigt ich will als
drittes noch hinzufügen aus unserem
themenkatalog heute der pakt für
rechtsstaat der hervorragend
vorangekommen ist und umgesetzt wurde
wir haben jetzt bis ende des jahres
diesen jahres bundesweit 2000
zusätzliche stellen für den ganzen
bereich der justiz der richterinnen und
richter und staatsanwältinnen und
staatsanwälte schaffen können
ausgangspunkt für diese für diese
gemeinsame kraftanstrengung von bund und
ländern waren natürlich auch die
situation der flüchtlings zuwanderung
2015/2016 jahren gemerkt wir müssen in
vielen verfahren
besser und schneller werden und
digitalisierung ist ein thema beim
besser und schneller werden
entsprechende personalausstattung und
personalqualifizierung ist ein zweites
thema und das haben wir vorangetrieben
und entsprechend umgesetzt bis auch in
polizeistrukturen hinein so dass eben
der rechtsstaat mit all seinen
möglichkeiten handlungsfähig ist oder
noch handlungsfähiger wird also dass wir
hier mit bundes und landes geld so einen
klaren schwerpunkt setzen konnten und so
zeitnah es auch umsetzen konnten das war
glaube ich sehr sehr wichtig
abschließend von mir auch noch mal etwas
zum thema corona ja wir freuen uns alle
darüber dass wir so viel normalität wie
möglich jetzt auch darstellen können wir
sehnen uns alle
danach gestern habe ich in berlin die
berlinale eröffnet die berlinale war
2020 die letzte größere veranstaltung
die stattgefunden hat danach wurde alles
größere abgesagt und dem berlinale ist
jetzt nach über einem jahr die erste
größere veranstaltung die wieder
stattfindet und da merkt man auch was in
diesem einen jahr uns verloren gegangen
ist ja auch in allen bundesländern
aber wir spüren eben auch wie sich alle
danach sehen dass jetzt die normalität
wirklich wieder gelebt werden kann
aber ganz klar ist auch diese normalität
muss verbunden sein mit der nötigen
vorsicht die bundeskanzlerin hat eben
darauf aufmerksam gemacht
wir sind gut vorangekommen auch wieder
in einer gemeinsamen anstrengung aber
wir haben auch noch viel zu tun
und insofern spielt das tatsächlich eine
wichtige rolle
was die cds jetzt vor allen dingen auch
erarbeiten werden wir fangen nicht bei
null an wir haben erfahrungen aus den
letzten monaten wir haben grundlagen wie
man mit großveranstaltung mit konzerten
und sportveranstaltungen umgehen kann
das ganze muss aktualisiert werden weil
wir vorangekommen sind mit dem thema
testen und impfen
da kann vieles angepasst werden aber wir
müssen uns darüber auseinandersetzen wie
geht es weiter mit großen
musikveranstaltungen die durch das ganze
land ziehen waren in dem einen drei tage
später in einem anderen bundesland da
muss es zumindest ein
gemeinsamen rahmen geben ja muss
vielleicht nicht eins zu eins formuliert
werden und entsprechend umgesetzt werden
aber ein gemeinsamer an denen sich auch
veranstalter orientieren können bei
sport kultur veranstaltungen messen
kongressen das spielt alles eine rolle
also da sind wir in einem guten
austausch und werden uns ständig updaten
die bundeskanzlerin hat es dargestellt
wie wir über den sommer uns dazu auch
verständigen werden und ganz besonders
wichtig ist eben auch das thema
impfstoffe die gesundheitsminister
werden sich jetzt damit
auseinandersetzen wann können wir mit
welchen lieferung und welchen
größenordnung anlieferungen wieder
rechnen
aber uns von seiten der länder war auch
sehr wichtig dass wir noch einmal
festhalten konnten dass es nicht in
stein gemeißelt ist das am 30
die impfzentren vom netz gehen er
brauchen sie möglicherweise um noch mal
auch einen letzten schub in diese erste
impfkampagne zu bekommen und wir müssen
immer noch mit bedenken dass ja dann
schon in dem herbst auch möglicherweise
das nach hinten beginnt für diejenigen
die so weit also berlins regierender
oberbürgermeister michael müller der
vorsitzende der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz zurzeit wir
haben gerade kurs gehört es wurde
gesprochen über großveranstaltungen aber
das ganze ist vertagt worden
wir sprechen darüber mit thomas reich
hat unseren korrespondenten in berlin
thomas da muss ich kurz warten bis wir
gewechselt haben hallo thomas was ist da
nur los eigentlich wollte sich die runde
da heute gemeinsam darauf einigen ist
nichts daraus geworden ist nichts draus
geworden können sich nicht einig werden
konnte ich glaube das ist der
entscheidende punkt wenn man nicht mehr
weiter weißt dann gründe man ein
arbeitskreis ich glaube das war heute
wie diese frage wurde ausgegliedert in
dieser arbeitsgruppe auf ebene der chefs
der staatskanzleien die nun eine lösung
finden müssen
das hat sich im vorfeld schon angedeutet
dass man dann nicht zu potte kommen kann
weil auf der einen seite die allende
also die spd regierten bundesländer
gerne solche regelungen gehabt hätten so
wie michael müller der regierende
bürgermeister von berlin das eben auch
noch
gesagt hat und auf der anderen seite ran
die aaa länder also die unionsgeführten
länder inklusive baden württemberg die
das nicht so gut fanden
nun wird er eben auf ebene der sozusagen
zuarbeiter der ministerpräsidentin nach
einer lösung gesucht dann wird sich
irgendwas finden das navi deswegen
erstmal vertagt erstmal wissen nicht wie
es ausgeht mit dem public viewing oder
mit open airs ich wollte gerade sagen da
warten wir alle drauf emg zum falls ich
weiß sehr bald los und dann ist ein
bisschen die frage wo können wir alle
zusammen gucken die lage in deutschland
sieht ja insgesamt schon etwas besser
aus die kanzlerin aber gerade schon
gesagt sehr erfreulich christoph giesel
passt das ganze mal zu für uns zusammen
die korona zahlen in deutschland sinken
weiter
inzwischen liegt die sieben tage
incidents in allen bundesländern unter
35 den höchsten wert verzeichnete
baden-württemberg mit 25,9
in mecklenburg vorpommern liegt die
inzidenz bei nur 5,3 mit den sinkenden
zahlen wird auch immer mehr gelockert
denn auch unterschiedlich je nach region
und bundesland restaurants und geschäfte
dürfen vielerorts wieder mehr normalität
ermöglichen
auch drinnen wird nun immer öfter wieder
bewirtet auflagen gelten aber weiter
etwa abstands und hygieneregeln auch bei
kunst kultur und sport ist wieder mehr
möglich in manchen bundesländern gibt es
schon wieder kino und
theatervorstellungen unter freiem himmel
doch gerade was großveranstaltungen
angeht ist man von der vor corinna zeit
noch weit entfernt
auch bei der em die morgen beginnt große
public viewing veranstaltungen wie hier
vor dem brandenburger tor wird es in
diesem jahr eher nicht geben
immerhin können fußballbegeisterte wohl
aber auf übertragungen in biergärten und
gaststätten ausweichen
und in berlin ist mehr zugeschaltet karl
lauterbach spd gesundheitspolitiker karl
lauterbach ist das jetzt eine gute oder
eine schlechte nachricht dass sich die
länder da verteidigen und noch mal
irgendwie auch staatssekretär ebene
miteinander versuchen sich zu beraten
gute nachricht und in der tat ist muss
er jetzt relativ schnell entschieden
werden
und die tatsache die man zur bewertung
logisch also fakten liegen auf der hand
wir sehen relativ stabil
einen weiteren rückgang also der
fallzahlen im fortschritt ist auch
berechenbar von daher gibt es eigentlich
keinen grund weshalb man sich nicht
einigen konnte ich hatte eine einigung
begrüßt wie hätte denn ihre einigung
ausgesehen
die spd geführten bundesländer haben wir
gerade gehört von meinem kollegen thomas
reichert waren für eine vorsichtige
zulassung von großveranstaltungen die
cdu-geführten bundesländer wollten dass
er nicht wo stehen sie dass sie sind ja
eher bekannt dafür vorsichtig zu sein
und auch immer zu warnen
also in der tat groß veranstaltungen
erhältlich zum jetzigen zeitpunkt auch
für problematisch empfunden ich finde es
wichtig dass man also beispielsweise für
die europameisterschaft public viewing
zulässt im außenbereich mit richtigen
leuten bereicherung
lassen wir den außenbereich weiter
testen und das also abstände also
beachtet werden müssen
bei großveranstaltungen also ist es so
wenn man großveranstaltungen macht dann
ist das nur möglich wenn man also
diejenige die an der großveranstaltung
teilnehmen testet und darüber hinaus die
masken weiter nutzt dann kann man das
aus was ich machen weil dann ist also
quasi ein superding kaum mehr möglich
das sind aber da nur so
großveranstaltungen draußen und auch
nicht großveranstaltungen mit
unbegrenzter teilnehmerzahl soll muss
obergrenzen geben somit also dann man
hat sich da einigen können unter
bestimmten voraussetzungen diese
voraussetzungen etwas zahlen müssen mit
maske getestet und eben nicht allzu
dicht
aber wie viele menschen reden wir
großveranstaltungen ist ja ein dehnbarer
begriff das kann 100 500 tausend oder
zehntausend leute sein was würden sie
sagen wo es so eine grenze wo man sagt
das ist noch verantwortbar gerade wenn
wir draußen uns im sommer bewegen
es kommt einfach darauf an wie groß die
fläche ist auf der man sich dann
befindet und wieder einlass ist also
wenn beispielsweise der anlass so ist
dass man sich beim einfachst nicht also
sozusagen so nah kommt dass man sich
infizieren kann und das wirklich belegt
ist es ist ein test gemacht worden
und es wird bei der veranstaltung
ausgetragen
dann könnte ich mir sehr gut vorstellen
dass man großveranstaltungen bis zu 1000
menschen heute zulässt aber wie gesagt
dann muss der abstand da ist es muss
getestet sein es muss mit masken
stattfinden dann hielte ich das für
denkbar
weil wir wissen also dass also die
übertragung im wesentlichen durch die
superstar passiert und die superstar
dann können über die tasten bisschen
schnell das könnt ihr relativ gut
identifiziert werden jetzt gibt es ja
doch auch die befürchtung dass das wird
irgendwann eine vierte welle geraten
könnten wenn es nicht schnell genug geht
mit den impfungen
wir haben torsten leer gefragt professor
für klinische pharmazie an der
universität des saarlandes und der hat
uns das hier dazu gesagt das eine ist
die eine variante müsste sich in meinen
augen noch durchsetzen die
wahrscheinlichkeit ist nicht so gering
dass sich eine indische variante
beispielsweise in deutschland auch
durchsetzt auch wenn momentan erst bei 2
prozent sind der zweite punkt ist
sicherlich wir müssen gucken dass wir
weiter kämpfen also ein ganz wichtiger
aspekt im kampf gegen die pandemie ist
letztlich dass wir weiter eben von jetzt
vor allem auch bei diesen niedrigen
instanzen dass wir nicht die lust daran
verlieren oder vielleicht doch den
glauben der die hoffnung auch wenn wir
jetzt noch keinen impftermin haben
sollten wir uns für den niedrigen sie
denn neben nicht rügen lassen dass im
herbst neben die situation sich
eventuell wieder verschärfen könnte weil
was dann im herbst zum beispiel auch
noch dazukommen sind eben auch noch
verschlechterte wetterbedingungen das
heißt wir können uns nicht mehr so viel
im freien aufhalten
diese saisonalität unterstützung die wir
momentan erleben
könnte dann entsprechend oder wird dann
letztendlich auch wieder zurückgenommen
werden und dann irgendwann die karten
noch einmal neu gemischt und dann könnte
es eine vierte welle geben aber ich
glaube dass die krankenhäuser dann
besser aufgestellt sein werden weil
letztendlich die vor allem gefährdeten
patientinnen und patienten war schon
geimpft sind und damit die verläufe
wahrscheinlich deutlich milder sein
werden
laut aber würde das dann heißen dass wir
haben zwar eine vierte welle die ist
moderat nicht so viele schwere verläufe
dass wir dann nicht mehr zu diesen
schweren mitteln einschränkungen greifen
müssten die wir sie jetzt erlebt haben
genau davon gehe ich auch aus ist
ähnlich wie der kollege leer
ich glaube das ist also in der im herbst
also fernseh wellen geben und ich glaube
auch dass ähnliche varianten sich auch
in deutschland verbreitet sind ob sie
sich komplett durchsetzt oder nicht das
wissen wir noch nicht das wird davon
abhängen wie viele fälle wir insgesamt
bekommen aber sie wird auf jeden fall
eine große rolle spiele und da ähnlichen
war ja so wissen wir dass sie deutlich
ansteckender ist dass sie gleichzeitig
also ein stück weit resistenz gegen
einige der stoffe hat und also doch
weitaus schwereren verlauf hat in dieser
kombination ist ja sehr gefährlich das
wird kommen
wir haben dann auch das problem dass
einige derjenigen die früh geimpft
worden sind wir haben ja diejenigen die
am bedürftigsten gewesen sind höchste
risiko trugen damit zuerst geben die
eltern und diejenigen die also
verpackung haben gerade in dieser gruppe
verliert aber der impfstoff zuerst seine
wirkung ist das am längsten er und
allgemein also ist die erst einmal
immunität bei diesen menschen so dass
damals in zukunft schneller nachlässt
dann müssen wir schnell nach hinten
wir werden zur mitte seiner situation
kommen wo wir im herbst wieder
mitbewohner zu tun haben wir werden also
probleme haben in den schulen
die stiko hat sich nicht also
durchringen können die impfung der
service 18-jährigen schüler zu empfehlen
das bedeutet dass wir in den schulen
dann tatsächlich probleme werden
bekommen denn jeder erwartet dass wir
regulären unterricht machen dass wenn
wir da noch machen müssen und wenn wir
das machen dann werden schüler hat sich
infizieren
wir werden bei denjenigen die also die
immunantwort nicht so gut ist
beispielsweise bei menschen mit rheuma
aber auch bei anderen auch die
monatskarten krebskranken also dass die
immunantwort nicht so gut da hätte
irgendwo auch nicht so stark wäre der
probleme haben und bei den älteren hohe
sozusagen die impfung an wirkung
verliert das wird alles wieder zu fällen
führen dass wir doch alles in der
zufahrt aus anweisungen führen und das
ist auch für die betroffenen ist das
also alles andere
als angenehm aber die impfung werde
etwas den schweren verlauf abbremst und
sozusagen und wir werden nachweisen
können
das wollte ich gerade sagen sie haben
auch schon vorgegriffen die ständige
impfkommission hat heute nachmittag vor
ungefähr einer stunde
tatsächlich ist die empfehlung
rausgekommen wir können's kurz
zusammenfassen also es wird empfohlen
kinder mit schweren vorerkrankungen und
erhöhtem risiko eines schweren cupid 19
verlauf es zu impfen mit dem
bayern-ticket of community alle anderen
kinder jugendliche ab zwölf für die gibt
es keine allgemeine impfempfehlung aber
es ist möglich zu impfen in absprache
mit dem jeweiligen behandelten arzt oder
ärztin und der ja mit dem einverständnis
der risikoabwägung jetzt habe ich hier
ein paar fragen herr lauterbach sie
kennen das ja schon
hier gibt es zum beispiel eine frage in
den usa gibt es volle stadien mit
zehntausenden zuschauern und kaum
ausschlagen die zahlen gehen runter
wieso sollte das hier nicht gehen
ähnlich in dänemark er muss noch mal
kurz vorliegen dass der kommentar von b
ähnliche dänemark da gibt es auch einen
dermaßen pflicht und es dort soll
deutlich mehr fans zugelassen werden
im kopenhagener stadion 25.000 statt der
bislang geplanten 16.000 zuschauer
dürfen dann die em spiele im stadion in
kopenhagen verfolgen
warum sind sie dabei uns so zögerlich
während andere länder sagen ja wir und
liegen wieder los ist ihnen der markt
das ist ja noch geplant das hat nicht
stattgefunden hat auch das wirklich
funktioniert ist die ist die frage also
da muss man vorsichtig sein und in den
vereinigten staaten geht leider muss man
sagen die inzidenz nicht mehr zurück das
problem ist den die amerikaner haben ein
bisschen zu schnell gelockert und da
wird auch noch aus so weitergehen
die impfquote ist höher als bei uns
unfallzahlen sinken nicht mehr kanzler
liegt herz hat ungefähr also bei 24 25
also sich von bundesstaat zu bundesstaat
anders auf die ähnliche variante
verbreitet sich ja dies schon sechs
prozent nimmt zu somit also ist die
eröffnung die wir in
den vereinigten staaten sehen kein
vorbild wir aber eine 24er incidents ist
ja jetzt keine katastrophen mehr
na ja das muss man sich ja so überlegen
was das bedeutet dass 24 der inzidenz
bedeutet eben dass ich dann wenn ich das
jetzt auf deutschland um rechnen würde
dann hätte ich also immerhin noch also
beispielsweise um die hundert tote pro
tag
und da kann ich war man gewöhnt sich
schnell an die todesfälle
aber es ist bitter ich bin gestern zum
beispiel auf dieser großen chor wird in
den situationen 43 der seite gelesen es
wahrscheinlich größten in deutschland
dass sich die schicksale dort anschauen
also wie dort die menschen um ihr leben
ringen zum tages- wochen- der jüngste
patient nicht gestern gesehen habe war
29 das alles nicht nötig und daher würde
ich tatsächlich also noch etwas
vorsichtig sagen also eine stabile
incidents 25p nicht wahr dass sich die
werden einfach so also das wert ist es
einfach sehr viel sinnvoller
also da noch etwas vorsichtig zu sagen
dass man die residenz sauber in den
niedrigen einstelligen bereich also
unter zehn tatsächlich ja unter zehn
ganz genau
oder sind sie der meinung dass eine
inzidenz von 25 wenn wir die jetzt für
die nächsten monate hätten ob das also
wäre das akzeptabel
also ich meine meinung spielt er keine
rolle das ist das ist das erste mal dass
sie wir können es wir können das mal
hier in den chat einfach fragen also ich
glaube dass mal weiter an die zuschauer
innen einfach mal mit ja antworten wenn
ihr denkt eine 25er instituts wäre
vertretbar und wir machen dann einfach
tatsächlich ein normales leben wie vor
der pandemie und nein antworten wenn ihr
sagt nein das ist eine zu risikoreich es
gibt aber jetzt zum beispiel menschen da
hängt die ganze existenz schon seit
einem jahr am seidenen faden oder ist
schon passiert
die teilweise abgerauscht zum beispiel
die konzert und veranstaltungswirtschaft
der bundesverband hat vor dem bund
länder treffen die korona politik
kritisiert ein zitat des präsidenten
jens michow oder sagte es ist nicht
erkennbar was noch geschehen soll damit
die branche endlich wieder geld
verdienen kann
anstatt auf staatliche hilfen angewiesen
zu bleiben er sagt also die branche sei
in der lage nur geimpften getesteten
oder genesenen personen in zukunft zu
gewähren und erfordert deswegen
rahmenbedingungen die veranstaltungen
ohne abstandsregeln wieder möglich sein
können herr lauterbach warum halten sie
das auch anscheinend ja nicht für eine
gute idee einfach zu sagen okay geimpft
klar getestet oder genesen kann sich
wieder in so einer veranstaltungs halle
oder im freistaat muss rahmen bewegen
wie 2009 10 das wird ja auch bald der
fall sein das wird wirklich bald der
fall sein
aber zum jetzigen zeitpunkt ist einfach
schlicht ergreifend also eine situation
wo ich dann noch einmal mit dem feuer
spielen wo ich dann wenn ich pech habe
doch den ein oder anderen superstar
übersehen wer das wirklich
also hundertprozentig gemacht wäre wenn
also jetzt also durchgeführt worden
wären wenn man sich darauf verlassen
könnte das also die positiven fälle auf
also zumindest die super später alle
identifiziert worden sind dann könnte
man das macht das wird bald kommen das
wird wirklich also ich mich wirklich nur
über wenige wochen dann wird man so
etwas machen können aber zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt ist es einfach so wir sind im
moment wirklich in einem guten lauf die
fallzahlen sehr drastisch nur dazu
bekommen deutlich unter zehn zu schaffen
und das wäre mehr als die paar wochen
noch wert also ich schaue mir die
perspektive
ich schaue mal kurz hier was bei uns im
chat los ist ist nicht repräsentativ
muss man natürlich dazu sagen deswegen
wirklich nur ein stimmungsbild von
unseren zuschauerinnen hier und da zähle
ich 123456 neins ein einziges jahr also
hier 12345 so weder noch schreibt einer
also ja wenn hygienemaßnahmen noch
eingehalten werden
also tatsächlich sind die meisten der
jetzt abgestimmt habe
und ihre meinung kundgetan haben auf
ihrer seite herr lauterbach
vielen dank dass sie heute wieder für
uns zeit hatten uns das ein bisschen
erklärt haben ihre meinung erläutert
haben und ich wünsche ihnen noch einen
schönen rest tag ich da gehen sie die
gelegenheit und wir schauen jetzt mal
tatsächlich wie das in der gastronomie
aussieht denn wie schon sagte die wirte
und wirtinnen die hängen seit über einem
jahr am seidenen faden manche haben es
nicht geschafft andere drängen jetzt
tatsächlich auf die öffnungen es geht
hier auch voran muss man sagen in fast
allen bundesländern auch teilweise
drinnen und draußen jetzt bei dem guten
wetter sowieso und für uns ist dominik
müller russ l nach köln gefahren hat
sich an den biergarten am aachener
weiher niedergelassen und dominik wie
ist denn dort die stimmung ja richtig
wir sind hier in köln am biergarten am
aachener weiher dass einer der wenigen
biergärten in köln die sehr zentral
gelegen sind und vor einer woche ist es
hier wieder losgegangen mit der
gastronomie nach langen monaten in denen
der biergarten geschossen sein musste
seit dieser woche ist es jetzt so dass
man als gast hier auch platz nehmen kann
ohne corona test also sprich man muss
keinen negativen krohn attest vorlegen
um platz nehmen zu können beginnt zu
werden und das ist ganz neu hier in köln
zumindest in der gastronomie ab morgen
braucht man solch einen test auch nicht
mehr der innen gastronomie ich glaube
darüber über diese nachrichten ist kaum
jemand so froh wie die wirte und die
gastronomen hier in köln und hierbei
hier steht jetzt josef frey ist der wirt
des biergartens am aachener weiher ja
wie froh wir erleichtert waren sie und
ihr team als sie gehört haben
es kann wieder losgehen also ich kann
das nicht mehr beschreiben ich habe mich
so gefreut über diese nachricht weil sie
sind ja eigentlich seit über 34 ja
einfach zu hause
wir machen nichts außer sitzen und
warten und die kosten laufen uns ja auch
weiter und wir
haben gerne einkommen und monatlich
hilft natürlich der bundesregierung
während langer werte aus dem markt und
da habe ich nicht wirklich riesig
gefreut wie ist das jetzt wie leben die
gäste das wieder ankommen die gäste
strömen die gäste hierher oder wifi lage
also die geste wäre ich sehr sehr gerne
an ein wenig ja das klingt an langsam zu
füllen ja aber nicht so wie in frage vor
der bewohner das braucht ein bisschen
zeit glaube ich damit die leute sich
anders orientieren
ja das wird sicherlich nicht einfach
aber wir sie haben ihn wieder auf das
ist was zählt und jetzt geht auch noch
die europameisterschaft ab morgen bei
ihnen wird man auch public viewing
machen können was versprechen sie sich
davon
also das verspreche ich mir schon
einiges auf jeden fall würden wir hier
die leute glücklich machen und es werden
auch sehr gut besucht allerdings
natürlich mit weniger seien ausgelastet
zwei jahren wir haben aber auch die
bestuhlung auch viel weniger als vor
zwei jahren
wir müssen das ja nachdem sie in der
regel halt das ist ein drittel
eigentlich vor zwei jahren wir hatten
vor zwei jahren wir haben sie zuletzt
davon 900 sitzplätze wir haben jetzt 300
350 maximal also wie man sie sehen es ja
schon dass da ein drittel aber ist er
halt weiß es besser als zu hause sitzen
haben jahre alt morgen public viewing
wird wieder möglich sein ja genau wir
haben da ja noch einen ton auch von
professor thorsten leer professor für
pharmakologie an der universität des
saarlandes dann haben wir ja schon
einmal vorgespielt und den haben wir
auch gefragt was er von public viewing
und eben solchen zusammenkünften in
biergärten hält es lässt sich pauschal
nicht beantworten ich glaube es kommt
sehr auf die veranstaltungen
ich glaube schon dass man solche
veranstaltungen irgendwie sicher
hinbekommen kann aber am ende des tages
müssen wir auch schauen dass wir hier
und jetzt wirklich auch kein ei ins nest
legen und hier keine neue
infektionsquelle schüren jetzt vor allem
aber bei den guten temperaturen
vielleicht dabei der feuchtfröhliche die
bei der em aufkommen kann
ich erwarte wenn dann durch diese public
viewings vor allem kleinere lokale
ausbrüche möglicherweise die die
gesamten sident hoffen
nicht so sehr beeinflussen aber
vielleicht von einem speziellen stadt
oder landkreis natürlich doch die noch
mal in die höhe treiben können also
soweit die einschätzung des fachmanns
die wirtin dass da gehandhabt in köln
also welche regeln gibt es welche
abstandsregeln gibt es kann man da
tatsächlich eng beieinander stehen vor
der leinwand und sich in die arme fallen
oder kommt dann der kellner und sagt
leute auseinander
also stehen wird man hier gar nicht
können und eng beieinander sein wird man
auch nicht können
ich gebe die frage direkt weiter an
josef frey ist welche konzepte gibt es
hier welche sicherheitsmaßnahmen welche
regeln greifen
wie wird das aussehen mit dem public
viewing dieses jahr also auf jeden fall
die hygiene frau kunst als nummer eins
da müssen wir wirklich ganz streng
darauf achten dass die gäste wenn sie
sich freuen sich aufzustehen gehen ihm
zur toilette gehen dass sie masken
anziehen dass die hände diese
funktionieren dass sie nicht versammeln
zusammen dass das ist sehr wichtig für
uns damit wir hier lange bleiben dürfen
ja wir haben sicherlich auch security
hier die das ganze auch kontrolliert
weil bei 3 400 leute können wir nicht
alleine alles sehen und da muss man ja
eigentlich klar und deutlich zeigen dass
hier der nicht an unserem konzept macht
dann gehört da nicht hin wenn wir
dachten
leider ausgehen müsse hier ist das mit
den monitoren wie wird das aussehen
werden die monitore überall seinem
biergarten oder wie werden die
positioniert sein dass es eben nicht zu
menschenansammlungen kommen vielleicht
auch außerhalb vom biergarten also
spricht dass nicht so viele leute
draußen vor dem biergarten stehen und
reingucken
also wir haben ja die fernseher so
positioniert dass sie eigentlich nur für
die gäste die da sitzen und jene die
stehen hier hat kein platz bei uns
wir haben zwölf monitoren in zwei kleine
leinwände man könnte aus dem biergarten
so wie es so ist von jeder seite auch
den fußball sehen weil er nicht will
kann man den fernseher ausschalten
wie wird das sein wenn sagen wir mal
deutschland ein tor schießt und die
leute sich in den armen liegen oder wenn
dann eben doch zu viele leute draußen
stehen also sind die emotionen in
sekunden zeit und das kann man sich
leicht jetzt sage ich mal
diese emotionen kontrollieren es ist
verdammt ich mir ja wenn alle auf einmal
so stehen müssen dahin gehen dann sitzen
sie wieder da und da kann auch dass in
kürze auch nicht so hinterher gehen also
solche emotionen natürlich kontrollieren
wäre das aber sie wissen des jahres
sekunden sind zu gründen
der erste ist kontrolliert das weiter
wahrscheinlich nicht
ich glaube das hat das kölner
ordnungsamt ja auch angekündigt man wird
kontrollieren man wird auch mit augenmaß
kontrollieren also emotionen klar sind
zugelassen
aber es wird in der tat so sein wenn zb
jetzt zu viele menschen vor dem
biergarten stehen wenn man sich generell
nicht an die regeln hält dann wird auch
das ordnungsamt einschreiten und dafür
sorgen dass die veranstaltungen dass er
das übertragung unterbrochen wird
aber es ist unterm strich so alle sind
sehr froh darüber das public viewing
wieder stattfinden kann und ja ab morgen
geht es los und die biergärten hier die
wirte die gastronomen die versprechen
sich dann noch sehr viel dafür
dominik vielen dank für diese eindrücke
nach köln und dann hoffen wir dass das
alles gut klappt und dass ist die pure
team nicht zu oft einschreiten muss also
auch die bitte an euch alle
wenn ihr im biergarten oder irgendwo
anders draußen zusammen guckt immer noch
ein bisschen zusammenreißen ist glaube
ich die bessere
variante als wieder so tun als ob nichts
gewesen wäre
wir haben ja zu anfang des teams gesehen
die merkel pk also bundeskanzlerin
merkel und die ministerpräsidentinnen
nach ihrem bund-länder-treffen und
angela merkel hat zu den corona zahlen
und zum generellen verlauf der pandemie
folgendes gesagt die entwicklung ist
extrem erfreulich zurzeit was die
fallzahlen anbelangt und wir können
sagen dass sich die anstrengungen der
vergangenen monate gelohnt haben dass
sich die erfolge jetzt auch zum teil
schon einstellen dass das wetter
natürlich auch seinen beitrag dazu
leistet aber wir dürfen nicht vergessen
corona ist damit nicht verschwunden und
das was uns sorge macht ist die
sogenannte delta variante die sich jetzt
in großbritannien wieder sehr stark
ausbreitet und dort im augenblick gerade
zu einem exponentiellen wachstum führt
und deshalb fühlen wir uns bestätigt
seitens des bundes dass wir sehr starke
einschränkung einreisebeschränkungen
gemacht haben für großbritannien und für
indien auch früher indische variante
genannte variante
sie ist augenscheinlich in ihrer
ausbreitung aggressiver das heißt wenn
man sozusagen die freie bewegung
ermöglicht dann wird sie sich gegenüber
der sogenannten britischen variante auch
wieder durchsetzen und wir sind im
grunde in einem wettlauf mit dem impfen
jeder tag den wir eine geringe
nachweisbarkeit dieser variante haben
ist ein guter tag wir sind jetzt bei 25
prozent
der anstieg ist recht langsam im
augenblick und ich hoffe dass das so
bleibt ja also hoffnungen aus dem
bundeskanzleramt sprechen doch mal mit
thomas reichert unseren korrespondenten
in berlin über ja die eher etwas mauern
ergebnisse des bund länder treffen swiss
corona angeht vorher aber noch mal eine
ganz kurze bitte an alle die
kommentieren
wir machen das sehr gerne mit euch wir
lesen auch gerne kommentare vor aber wie
immer gilt bitte sag nicht bleiben und
wir löschen natürlich auch kommentare
weil sich hier joana mai auf facebook
zum beispiel wundert warum bekommen
da schon ob sie die wahrheit auf der
angst hätten dass die menschen die
wahrheit erfahren
nein die wwe löschen kommentare die
ersten news verbreiten oder lügen oder
propaganda genauso wie kommentare die
beleidigend sind oder entweder uns oder
andere kommentatoren beleidigen das
löschen wir das steht auch ein etikett
kannst du dir auf zdf.de alles
durchlesen ansonsten kann hier stehen
bleiben was stehen bleiben kann
aber ich würde ich zum beispiel bitten
aufzuhören unsere gesprächspartner zu
unterstellen dass sie alkoholisiert
werden also das ist einfach ne das ist
finde ich unseriös lassen wir trotzdem
einfach jetzt mal so stehen
thomas ich habe ich hier eine frage ich
weiß nicht ob sie beantworten kannst wir
probieren das einfach mal das ist die
quasi hier auch das charakteristikum
unseres livestreams hier fragt sich
warum können im biergarten 500 menschen
zum public viewing also zur em
ach so zeigt es nicht mag ihre es auch
hier da ist es aber ein helge schneider
oder olli schulz kann kein konzert auf
einer wiese machen oder ist das
vielleicht doch irgendwann bald möglich
thomas frage beides findet im freien
statt insofern gilt die regel dass wohl
forscher das vergnügen tapsten freien
dass man die befragung nicht so
gefährlich ist die länder suchen im
moment hat sich danach hier entgegen und
einen versuch war da heute im
bundeskanzleramt eine gemeinsame linie
zu finden das hat nicht geklappt
ich kann die frage nicht ganz genau
genannt worden
was ich sagen kann ist sozusagen was das
politisch hier in berlin dahinter steckt
wir sind auf der einen seite der
situation wollte sich freuen dass es
warm wird und sonnig und auf der anderen
seite die inzidenz zahlen runter gehen
und wir sind mitten im wahlkampf und
deswegen will auf der einen seite keine
spielverderber sein und weder ein
konzert von helge schneider noch public
viewing verdienten auf der anderen seite
könnt man auch den politischen gegner da
nicht unbedingt gegen erfolg und als
drittes haben wir gerade angela merkel
gehört die nach wie vor ihre alten linie
treu bleibt sozusagen das team vorsicht
wieso das mal genannt hat zu bilden der
teamcaptain dieses vorsichts teams sie
hat den vorteil dass sie im september
nicht noch mal zu
sie stellen müssen so können da ganz
ihrer linie treu bleiben kann
andere wie zum beispiel bodo ramelow
ministerpräsident in thüringen
der ist das schon viel weiter er hofft
dass seine letzten linkspartei da besser
abschneiden und sagte jetzt gerade vor
kurzem ich glaube wir können das risiko
der kompletten öffnung im herbst
eingehen
also insofern gute nachrichten für alle
die möglichst bald konzert in freien
anhören wollen und public viewing machen
wollen
auf der anderen seite natürlich auch ein
gewisses risiko muss man dazu sagen
neben karl lauterbach gehört und die
virologen also es ist wie immer in
dieser krone pandemie hinter allem
hinter allen regelungen steckt auch ein
politischer streit zumal jetzt dass man
wirklich hier in berlin merkt wie sehr
der bundestagswahlkampf dann langsam an
fahrt aufnimmt was der
gesundheitsminister und die zum thema
großveranstaltungen hat er da auch eine
meinung
wir haben hier heute vormittag heute
mittag die mir gehört bei einer
pressekonferenz mit lothar wieler dem
präsidenten des robert-koch-instituts
beide wieder und sparen waren so
vorsichtig abwägen keiner von beiden hat
sich das explizit dagegen ausgesprochen
spannend sagte ja
die zahlen seien erstaunlich ermutigend
man könne jetzt mehr wagen in zweifel
auch veranstaltungen im freien mit mehr
leuten so lange man sich an die
abstandsregel hält so lange getestet
wird möglichst auch viele geimpfte dabei
sind und public viewing wird dass
fußballfans wird das vielleicht weniger
freuen in dem man wirklich dann auch
wenig alkohol zu sich nimmt selbst wenn
deutschland gewinnt das war sein rat
aber war anders als sonst nicht wenige
auch nur teil wieder nicht na ja gesagt
hätten kommt auf keinen fall in frage
ja ich habe ja auch ein kommentar der
passt dazu tatsächlich hier von sepp der
meint das merkt man schon in den
biergärten
sobald das dritte bier weg ist hängt die
maske beim klar auf beim gang aufs klo
runter abstände werden nicht mehr
eingehalten und so weiter also da auch
die befürchtungen dass gerade das mit
denen zusammen sein und mit dem
alkoholkonsum dazu führen kann dass
menschen nicht mehr so vorsichtig sind
wie sie es eigentlich sein sollten dann
gab es von jens spahn heute auch noch
neuigkeiten in sachen digitaler im
das ging doch schneller offenbar als
zunächst gedacht
intrigen hat uns das mal zusammengefasst
die sommerferien stehen an und ein
digitaler impfpass soll das reisen in
europa erleichtern einen code auf dem
smartphone einfach und überall lesbar
praktischer als das alte gelbe heftchen
viele andere impfungen drin dass man die
nicht verliert auch der
gesundheitsminister ganz stolz heute
morgen präsentierte er den digitalen
impfausweis den sogenannten kopf pass es
geht jetzt los schritt für schritt
werden impfzentren arztpraxen apotheken
angeschlossen aber nicht alle sind heute
oder morgen schon angeschlossen
innerhalb der nächsten wochen sind dann
alle dabei so das so ist die zielmarke
bis ende juni
der kompass in deutschland für alle die
wollen auch zur verfügung steht
geduld ist also noch gefragt doch was
ist mit den schon fast 19 millionen
deutschen die doppelt geimpft sind und
möchten dass ihre impfung aus dem gelben
impfausweis übertragen wird in die
digitale ebhauser ärzte befürchten einen
ansturm in dieser praxis in hamburg geht
es allein um 500 patienten die dann alle
auf einmal wenn dieser code frei
geschaltet wird oder diese app
freigeschaltet wird
dann natürlich zu mir kommen und das
haben wollen 500 kontakte so nebenbei
ist ziemlich anstrengend
die apotheken sollen daher helfen beim
umschreiben von papier auf digital im
pass und personalausweis reichen
kooperiert wird mit dem
robert-koch-institut und selbst wer den
digitalen impfausweis heute oder in den
nächsten tagen noch nicht in der hand
hält kein problem das gelbe heftchen
gilt weiterhin als nachweis weltweit
das ging dann doch recht schnell sind
dass jetzt die guten nachrichten die
jens spahn dringend gerade braucht steht
ja doch sehr unter beschuss ja es ging
jetzt schnell sozusagen eine
punktlandung mit quietschenden reifen
vor dem beginn der sommerferien aber
wenn man so ein bisschen esse ich da in
sparens wein gießen will es ist kommt am
ende doch relativ spät
die frage digitale im haus weist die
stellt jetzt nicht dass kurz vor den
sommerferien sollen die stellte sich in
wahrheit schon im herbst vergangenen
jahres und zum beispiel der landkreis
altötting hat einen sehr vorausschauend
eilantrag der damals schon im herbst
letzten jahres angefangen hat zu seinem
landkreis selbst ein digitalen ausweis
in auftrag zu geben
den gab es dann im januar er hat man in
darüber informiert oder die wollten
darüber nicht recht was wissen sondern
hat wie so oft in dieser pandemie dann
ihre eigene lösung aufgesetzt mit
verschiedenen großen konzernen das hat
nun lange gedauert
kurz vor den sommerferien kommt noch
dazu dass es klappt aber das problem
dass sven richten gerade in seinem
beitrag beschrieben hat das ist
natürlich da millionen menschen wurden
schon geimpft das ist gut für die für
die fäden um der panne für die hausärzte
ist es eine große herausforderung für
die apotheken möglicherweise ein
weiterer zu gewinnen womit wir sozusagen
beim zweiten thema werden er hat wie
jens spahn hat er heute nicht nur gute
nachrichten sondern er bekam aber
sozusagen eine art passion vom
bundesrechnungshof der ihm vorgehalten
hat dass er in dieser pandemie
steuergelder die besonders sparsam man
auch nicht besonders wirtschaftlich
eingesetzt hat beim masken kauft bei der
kompensation von krankenhäusern die da
an der belastungsgrenze mit den
intensivbetten arbeiten
und beim aufbau von intensivbetten
insgesamt in den krankenhäusern also
dieser bericht des bundesrechnungshofes
der kam ein paar stunden nach der
pressekonferenz von ihren spaß gutes
timing für ihn aber der inhalt der ist
doch kritischer was seine bisherige
tätigkeit da an geht das heißt eine
reaktion von sparen oder aus dem
gesundheitsministerium gibt es da noch
nicht es gibt in dem bericht selbst der
uns hier im auf der studie auch vorliegt
eine stellungnahme des des
bundesgesundheitsministeriums das im
wesentlichen darauf hinausläuft zb bei
der frage warum wurden
ffp zwei masken an bedürftige abgegeben
kostenlos abgegeben warum wurden dann
die so teuer brauchen wollte den
apotheken die die kostenlos abgegeben
wurden haben der preise städte die weit
über den marktüblichen preisen lagen da
geht es um wirklich milliardenschwere
ausgaben das
bundesgesundheitsministerium hat in
seiner rechtfertigung erklärt es hält er
eben schnell gehen müssen dann habe ich
versucht marktübliche preise abzubilden
bei den erstattungen für die apotheken
aber der bundesrechnungshof in seinem
bericht scheint davon nicht besonders
überzeugt zu sein
jetzt gibt es noch so ein paar fragen
die sind schwierig zu beantworten
wahrscheinlich können wir dann nicht so
richtig viel sagen ich kenne sie
trotzdem mal an thomas vielleicht fällt
ja doch was ein oder du hast tatsächlich
in den tag und information
thomas schönberger möchte wissen
entfällt die quarantäne pflicht bei der
einreise aus uk und anderen varianten
gebieten sobald die delta variante auch
in deutschland dominant ist also wenn es
auch dass hier bei uns gibt muss man
dann nicht mehr in quarantäne das
scheint mir nicht so richtig logisch zu
sein oder was dazu das zu tun ist also
die aktuell gültige einreisebestimmungen
sieht das nicht vor und ich kann im
moment davon absehen das ist politisch
oder irgendeiner weise eine vorbereitung
gebe dass das geändert wird im moment
ist es so dass wir aus virusvarianten
gebieten mit ok nach deutschland kommt
in jedem fall für 14 tage in quarantäne
musste kann sich da auch nicht frei
testen daraus das ist sozusagen die
härteste gangart hat auch zu spannungen
fraktion zwischen der region sondern und
berlin geführt
die briten sind sowieso verschnupft
wegen des brh exit und gegen den zähen
verhandlungen mit der eu david böcking
seit ich im moment ein bisschen hat man
den eindruck dass man sich gegenseitig
transferiert wobei natürlich geht die
virusvariante dieser version ist
gefährlich ist der christie's in der
ansteckung und sofern ein das ist glaube
ich im moment nicht absehbar wer als uk
zurückkommt der wird hier in die längere
quarantäne gehen müssen und zwar auch in
absehbarer zeit wird das so sein dann
gibt es eine e mail von roskosmos der
der über die möchte wissen wann werden
die kontakt beschränkungen komplett
aufgehoben ist das abhängig von der
instituts ich glaub so weit will noch
niemand richtig denken in berlin oder so
weit will sagen wir mal mit ausnahme von
bodo ramelow der wie gesagt
spätestens im herbst dann alle
einschränkungen aufgehoben sehen will
so leute sonst eigentlich noch niemand
wirklich denken was jetzt ansteht ist
die verlängerung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes das ende juni
ausläuft und das parlament dann um
weitere drei monate verlängern soll
die stimmen der großen koalition also
von cdu csu und spd gelten da sicher die
fdp hat heute erklärt sie würde das
infektionsschutzgesetz der am liebsten
diese regelungen auslaufen lassen indem
eben gerade nicht erklärt wird dass wir
eine pandemie im land haben von
nationaler bedeutung das ist die
begründung zu diesen ausnahmen regeln
die im moment gelten und die nach dem
willen der großen koalition noch einmal
drei monate verlängert werden sollen
die andere nachricht ist dass im
bundestag dann auch über die so genannte
bundes notbremse demnächst entschieden
wird in den nächsten tagen die sollen
als sich der großen koalition
und aus sicht der meisten anderen
fraktionen im bundestag nicht verlängert
werden weil die indexwerte in allen
landkreisen mainz sind
dass man davon abstand nehmen will
merkel hat allerdings auch bereits
angekündigt sollte es im herbst eine
vierte begeben
mit der indischen variante dann würde
man im zweifel auch diese bundes
notbremse wieder in kraft setzen also
dass ab einer inzidenz verwundet
automatisch in jedem landkreis bestimmte
beschränkungen eintreten am schärfsten
vielleicht die ausgangssperre wieder
erinnern uns noch alle daran
jetzt gab es aber tatsächlich heute die
fdp oder zumindest der innenpolitische
sprecher der fdp konzert in kuhle der
hatte im deutschlandfunk gesagt
angesichts steigender impfquoten und
sinkender incidents zahlen könnte man
doch jetzt nicht mehr von einer
epidemischen lage von nationaler
tragweite sprechen und deswegen möchte
er dass der bundestag morgen keine
verlängerung beschließt die realistisch
ist dass thomas also die die
einschätzung ob eine solche pandemie
vorliegt das liegt offenbar im auge des
betrachters und die liberalen die fdp
haben in den letzten ganzen monaten sich
auch selbst das partei profiliert wieder
in diesen aufziehenden wahlkampf als
jene die da mehr für lockerungen mehr
für liberalisierungen gegen die
einschränkung von bürgerrechten
aufgetreten sind
es gibt ich kann weit und breit dafür im
moment im bundestag keine mehrheit
erkennen das heißt es wird dort die die
pandemische lage verlängert werden und
damit auch das infektionsschutzgesetz
als begründung sagen großkoalitionäre
also aus union und spd auch oft dass an
diesem infektionsschutzgesetz auch jede
menge corona verbaut man daran hängen
das ist ja der kern dieses gesetz ist
das eben der bundestag dem bunte
exekutive die das mandat gibt die macht
gibt in dieser partie nicht schnell zu
reagieren mit verordnungen
es gehe insgesamt aktuell hängt gut 20
also fast zwei dutzend verordnungen dran
da geht es um das testen der geht es um
regelungen für kitas und wie eltern die
ihre kinder dahin bringen wollen
unterstützt werden können
also schon allein deswegen ist das
interesse wird meisten anderen
fraktionen so dass man sagt kommen wir
lassen das jetzt noch bestehen bis ende
september entschieden wird das ist das
interessante dann auch dann über den
september hinaus diese lage noch mal
verlängert wird anfang september also
kurz vor der bundestagswahl
dass daniel das könnte spannend werden
wie dann die parteien sich da
positionieren wenn der gang zur wahlurne
kurz bevor steht das definitiv ist ein
spannendes jahr ein spannender sommer
mit der bundestagswahl dann mit dieser
pandemischen lage ich habe ja noch ein
paar kommentare auf die möchte ich ganz
kurz eingehen also es gibt hier zum
beispiel kritik von niklas der sagt wo
man jetzt zwei apps für diesen digitalen
impfausweis ist möchte die lukb das
glaube ich auch noch machen dann hat man
drei hier also ne das ist die frage ich
würde sagen also natürlich ist es ein
bisschen verwirrend vielleicht aber
vielleicht hilft das auch diesen
impfausweis diesen digitalen so weit
verbreitet wie möglich zu machen andere
sagen aber hier ich muss mal kurz
schauen da habe ich einen kommentar
gesehen auf facebook der ging in die
richtung
es wäre schön wenn man sich ein bisschen
mehr zeit lassen würde bei der
entwicklung da auch dagegen dass wir die
meinungen auseinander tun hast du hast
gerade gesagt eigentlich hätte das schon
früher kommen sollen
aber auch die korona waren app ist er
relativ schnell aufgesetzt wurden hat
viel geld gekostet das ist dann ja immer
tatsächlich so eine subjektive abwägung
ob das gestein oder langsam ist na ja
das ist das ist total subjektiv ich
glaube bei der frage warum gibt es jetzt
zwei apps das ist glaube ich an den
gegen kommen für die nutzer insbesondere
für jene die sich aus welchen gründen
auch immer gegen die kontakt entschieden
haben die glauben obwohl die und
wirklich soweit ich das sehe sehr hohen
datenschutz
man stiegen entsprechend ich will dass
trotzdem nicht machen die aber trotzdem
die möglichkeit an wollen ihren impfen
einfach als digital vorweisen zu können
jeder der sonst die korona barren app
hat ich habe es heute schon immer auf
meiner app gesehen da ist die die dieses
tool schon installiert der kann das dort
machen
kann seinen code scannen und dann klappt
das hoffentlich auch bei den reisen
innerhalb der eu
also nochmal ich glaube das ist eher ein
entgegenkommen dass wer die korona
wahrheit nicht möchte dann eben trotzdem
einen digitalen fassen kann
das wird dann gibt es hier noch 2
kommentare da möchte ich ganz kurz
darauf eingehen also wir an gustavsson
schreibt auf facebook das war doch klar
dass man das verlängert das werden die
nie mehr los da wird man belogen von
vorne bis hinten ich glaube hier und da
müssen wir so ein bisschen einschränken
wir sehen dass sich die einschränkungen
lockern dass wir wieder mehr draußen
sein dürfen dass wir auch wieder die
gastronomie dürfe benutzen dürfen
das ist jetzt mit dem public viewing
losgeht wie wissen wir noch nicht das
war ja auch jetzt thema was wir
besprochen haben bund und länder konnten
sich dann nicht einigen da gibt es jetzt
einen arbeitskreis
und dann gibt es hier noch einen
kommentar von uhu wurde schon besprochen
dass nun immer mehr studien zu dem
ergebnis kommen die maßnahmen gelockt
bei uns brachten überhaupt nichts das
haben wir noch nicht besprochen weiß
nicht thema diese streams ist allerdings
ist diese aussage sehr sehr stark
verkürzt und in dieser verkürzung nicht
richtig ich habe mal hier unseren
faktencheck aufgelegt von meinen
kollegen oliver klein neue studie der
uni münchen war der shutdown unnötig und
wir kommen dazu den schluss bzw der
kollege oliver klein der unser fact
checker ist und sich immer sehr intensiv
mit den themen beschäftigt dass erstens
die wissenschaftler gar nicht zu diesem
schluss kommen dass der unnötig war
sondern sagen wir können das nicht
wirklich nachweisen eben weil es so
viele verschiedene faktoren gibt und sie
sagen auch sie möchten nicht dass diese
studie missbraucht wird um gegen lok
downs zu argumentieren also das können
wir euch gerne nochmal hier gleich in
die kommentare packen
damit ihr euch das genauer anguckt also
weitere maßnahmen hätten das
infektionsgeschehen durchaus beeinflusst
und auch weitere faktoren aber das
können mit den daten nicht auseinander
drosseln also diese schlussfolgerung das
ist nichts gebracht hat ist so nicht
richtig das kann man aus den daten
einfach so nicht ablesen
ich nehme den link jetzt kopieren und
packe ihn hier gleich bei euch in die
kommentare
dann könnt ihr euch das sehr gerne
durchlesen so
dann würde ich sagen thomas vielen dank
dass du uns das zusammengefasst hat
vielen dank für eure fragen und
kommentare fürs dabei sein und ich würde
sagen müssen uns beim nächsten live
wieder für morgen haben wir schon
eingeplant denn da soll irgendwas mit
fußball stattfinden und mit den m und
mit public viewing
ich glaube das wird einige interessieren
das sind auf jeden fall wieder live für
euch dabei bis dahin sage ich macht gut
und tschüss